[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Hi, this is Aja.
Welcome to episode 172 of
the "Google Cloud Platform"
Podcast.
We're here at Next,
and we're going
to be talking to a lot
of great folks today.
So let's get to that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
Let's do it.
DAN SKAGGS: Easy enough.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
super excited to have
an old friend of mine come join
the podcast today, Dan Skaggs.
How're you doing, Dan?
DAN SKAGGS: I'm doing well.
It's been a long time.
MARK MANDEL: It's
been a long time.
Dan and I know each other
through Adobe ColdFusion
for many, many years.
DAN SKAGGS: Way back in the day.
MARK MANDEL: Way
back in the day.
Yeah, Dan, do you want to tell
us a little bit about yourself
and what you do?
DAN SKAGGS: So currently,
I work for Viacom.
And I lead engineering teams,
building internal web app
suites for our content
supply pipeline,
from getting new music
videos and episodic content
movies from ingest, all the way
through to our central archive
and all of the
different steps that
are required to make
different renditions,
and metadata, and such, so.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic, and
what are you doing here at Next?
DAN SKAGGS: So we are
just starting our journey
into moving a bunch
of stuff into GCP.
And so this is kind
of a learning--
get up to speed on some
of the various offerings
and kind of see from an
architect standpoint, what
we can take advantage
of, as we're
looking to move
applications into GKE
and move media into
Google Cloud Storage.
So this is kind of an intro
to the whole ecosystem for me.
JON FOUST: Amazing.
So I'm pretty sure you're
pretty excited about a couple
of the announcements that
have come out of Google Next.
DAN SKAGGS: There's been
some good stuff here.
The Anthos product
looks amazing.
Of course, I don't
work personally
in our cloud engineering group.
I kind of work with them,
and I'm a customer of them.
So they're the one
making those decisions.
But we've been having a bunch
of conversations around dinner
and stuff around some things
that have been announced here
this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Then you said that you
had a couple of things
you wanted to talk about
that were particularly
interesting to you.
DAN SKAGGS: Yeah, so one
professional and one personal.
Professionally, my
teams are building
microservice
architecture-- rightsized
service they call it.
And so the Istio product,
looking for centralized,
consolidated management and
discovery of our services,
being able to not
have every team that's
building each one
of those services
have to worry about how to
integrate Active Directory
authorization, or make
sure that they're keeping
our infosec people happy,
being able to put that
on top of and kind of outside
of and apply it to our services.
There's just so many
benefits to doing that.
Plus, it gives us a
lot more visibility
across different sets of teams
that don't normally interact.
Hey, I need a service.
Well, somebody else already
over here has built this.
Let's see if we can use that.
So we're looking forward
to that from a couple
of different angles.
And our cloud
engineering folks are
really excited about getting
that up and going, too.
MARK MANDEL: What's been
one of your favorite things
that you've seen
in session so far?
I know you mentioned
a couple of things,
but I'm sure you
have other stuff.
DAN SKAGGS: One of the things
that most energized me,
I sat in a panel yesterday
called The Future of Health--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
DAN SKAGGS: With some folks from
consulting and the industry,
as well as people--
a lady from National Institutes
of Health and the Google Health
representative.
That was literally inspiring
and energizing hour from--
I'm a big advocate of people
having access to their own data
and owning their own data.
And when you look at it
from the health care side,
I would love nothing more than
to have all of my health data
where I can get my hands on it.
And if I go to a
new provider, then I
can say, OK, you get access to
this for the next five days.
MARK MANDEL: Here's my USB key.
DAN SKAGGS: Right, or I push
a button and the cloud says,
send it to his system, right?
It's even easier.
So that angle of it appeals to
me as a data geek, so to speak.
But then also the ability for
me to voluntarily push that
into big data to aid
in studies and research
and anonymize it and say--
be able to tell these
research organizations,
you can use my health
data for x purposes
and know that that's respected.
And some of the things that
they were talking about that are
coming and that they're working
on trying to get industry
standardization-- and of course,
we have some government rules
that are going to force a little
bit of that over the next year
or two--
is very exciting.
I have several
family members that
are in health care spaces,
various types of providers.
And so that's
something that's always
been kind of an energizing
thing for me to get in and talk
about.
And after having run a health
care startup for a few years,
too, it really is something
that hits pretty close to home.
JON FOUST: That's amazing.
I've actually done
a little health care
stuff in my past life.
Glad to see that we--
Google Cloud and a lot
of our health partners
are actually
fulfilling something
that really means a lot to you.
DAN SKAGGS: Yeah, they
had one stat where--
was it the Human Genome
Project took a billion dollars
in 10 years?
And then that was
in, I think, 2003.
By 2010, I believe, if I
remember the numbers correctly,
it took $10 million and months.
And so the advent of these
machine learning ecosystems
and the big data and
stuff to be able to squash
that time and the cost has
to be nothing but beneficial
for people that are
researching cures
for diseases and conditions
that we are experiencing now.
So it's just amazing.
MARK MANDEL: It's
just exciting stuff.
DAN SKAGGS: It is.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Dan, thank you so much
for coming and hanging out
with us--
DAN SKAGGS: You bet.
MARK MANDEL: On the show floor.
And I hope you enjoy
the rest of your Next.
DAN SKAGGS: Appreciate
you having me on.
MARK MANDEL: So I am
absolutely delighted to have
both Lauren and Aja sitting
here with the two Marks--
one-half of the Google Mark
club, I just want to be clear.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Slightly over one-half,
as we have 3 and 1/2 members.
MARK MANDEL: We have
3 and 1/2 members.
AJA HAMMERLY: Does Marc
with a C not count?
MARK MANDEL: No, Marc with--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh no--
MARK MANDEL: Oh no.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We have more.
Oh, wait, so is Marc with a
C-- let's discuss this later
when we can figure it out.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
talk about this later.
Anyway, so more
importantly, Lauren and Aja,
how are you both doing today?
LAUREN BUCHMAN:
I'm just pondering
how many Marks does it take
to promote Google Cloud right
now, so.
AJA HAMMERLY: All of them.
MARK MANDEL: Several.
More than several.
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm
a little tired.
We're two days into a very,
very large conference.
But everyone seems to be happy.
So that's great.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Lauren, do you
want to tell people
a little bit about yourself?
I know people know Aja
because Aja's super famous.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: Yeah, my
name's Lauren Buchman.
I work in the developer
relations team,
and I do developer marketing.
AJA HAMMERLY: And we like
Lauren because she understands
developers because she has
been through many of their pain
points.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: I
just didn't know
that that's what was happening.
AJA HAMMERLY: You don't have
to know about it at the time
to learn the valuable lessons.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: I tried
to deploy websites
for clients in the past.
And not knowing how to load
balance to WordPress sites,
I didn't realize I
was learning some
of those DevOps and deployment
pain points along the way, but.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, we brought you here today
to talk about the developer
keynote.
We were having an
interesting discussion
before where we're learning
all sorts of interesting stuff
about how that came to be.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, and
we've had a developer
keynote the last couple
of years at Next.
But figuring out what to
include in it is really hard.
And Lauren's got some
more insights on this.
But part of the
reason it's hard is
that we use the phrase
technical practitioner.
And there is a lot of different
people with different interests
under that label.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: Yeah, I
mean, when we were saying,
hey, what are some
things that we
can say as we're telling
people about Next
about why they should come?
It ended up being almost a
three page document, where
we were talking about, what is
a specific thing that a data
engineer will get out of
it versus a data scientist?
And not even talking
about app development
and are we going
to talk about what
it takes to write your apps,
but some of the backend stuff
that you need to make work.
So yeah, it's a diverse group.
AJA HAMMERLY: It
is a diverse group
and all sorts of backgrounds.
We've got folks who've
been doing this forever.
We've got folks who have
very tight ties to operator.
We've got folks more
like myself, who
kind of dabble in everything.
And we have approximate
knowledge of many things.
And we've got folks
who specifically
focus on very, very small
subsets of data science
related to specific industries.
And trying to build
content for all
of those people in
a compelling way
is really challenging,
as it turns out.
And as this event gets bigger
and as Google Cloud has
more products, it gets harder.
It doesn't get easier
with experience.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
what's the solution there?
I mean, do you just
keep abstracting upwards
until you're not talking
about anything in specific?
Or do you start
breaking out into more--
a keynote for data scientists,
and a keynote for developers,
and a keynote for operators?
AJA HAMMERLY: Well, we only have
one keynote stage, which makes
lots of things a challenge.
We have spotlight
sessions, which
are kind of like more
tailored keynote type things.
But I mean, the temptation
is there to abstract.
But as our lovely
podcast guests know,
when we have people who don't
talk about anything concrete,
it can get a little boring.
So I don't know if we
figured it out yet.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: Yeah,
I think you kind of
have to just say we're
going to talk about one
or two things in depth.
And not everybody
in the audience
is going to get exactly
what they're interested in.
But hopefully, it
will be valuable
because they may learn
a little bit about what
their colleagues or other
folks on their teams
are dealing with.
MARK MANDEL: So if people
didn't catch the livestream
or haven't yet watched
the YouTube recording,
can give us a brief
synopsis of the sort
of things people
actually saw on stage,
other than the two of you?
AJA HAMMERLY: So I'll
start with the first half,
and then maybe you
can take over and talk
about the second half, Lauren.
So we started out
with an app that
was written by several of our
PMs, and product managers,
and software engineers,
trying to demonstrate
bringing multiple of
our products together.
Because one of the
things that we've
heard from folks
in the past at Next
is that each org inside Google
talks about their launches,
but there isn't enough
content for folks
who are trying to bring a lot
of Google products together.
And that was our
Game of Life demo.
And we also showed
integrating with common tools,
like Jenkins and Slack.
And we had Slack
Ops as part of that.
And then I came on stage and
told people all the stuff
that they already know,
but like hearing again
about how to have
sustainable DevOps practices
and how you need a good team.
And then Lauren, that's
when you came on stage.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: I did, and
I was able to bring three
different customers on stage.
So we heard first from
a company called Wix.
You know Wix.
It's like a website
building tool.
And so they demoed
a new developer tool
that they've built
on top of GCP.
And we actually built
a chatbot on stage
in less than 60 seconds.
It's kind of fun,
like checking out
how you can find a
boat in the Bahamas
and seeing the natural
language in our--
AJA HAMMERLY: NLP.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: Yeah,
NLP, there it is.
But yeah, we built a chatbot
on stage in about 60 seconds
and got to see how that worked.
And then we had
Arctic come on stage.
And they showed us an Anthos
demo, which was kind of cool.
The demo gods were not on
our side at that point.
And somebody had not
actually logged into Jenkins,
so we had to follow
up a little bit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It was
handled super well, though.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, it was.
AJA HAMMERLY: And we now
know that it was a live demo.
It was not a prerecording.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: Yeah, exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Which is good to know.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: And then we
got to hear from this woman,
Twinkle Desai from Kohl's.
And she came out and
talked about how she's
been managing her SRE teams.
AJA HAMMERLY: And
then we had many
of your favorite
DevRellers and friends
doing five to 10 minute
demos of various things.
We had Emma, who I know was
on the podcast this week
and on the podcast in the past,
showing all of her awesome pie.
And we had captain BigQuery
himself, Felipe Hoffa--
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
AJA HAMMERLY: In
his cape because--
MARK MANDEL: Very important.
AJA HAMMERLY: He needed
a mask, but he also
says that he's too
pretty for a mask.
So he was showing us
all sorts of cool stuff
you can do with data, including
the fact that you can now
delete data from BigQuery,
which is something that people
have been asking for.
Steren talked to us about
what is this Cloud Run thing
that everyone's excited about.
And they deployed a
OpenOffice container--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fancy.
AJA HAMMERLY:
[INAUDIBLE] I mean,
the point is, is that
just because you have
an on-prem system,
you've got legacy code,
doesn't mean you can't
actually containerize stuff.
And I think that's a
super important message
for folks to get.
Because a lot of folks think
they can't try the new stuff
because their code's old.
And no, no, there's
lots of folks
who are putting really old
stuff, like Fortran and COBOL,
in containers.
And that's cool.
And then Cloud E--
not that Eric-- Eric
Schmidt showed up.
And he talked to the
chief data scientist,
I believe, from the
Golden State Warriors.
And they talked about the fact
that the Golden State Warriors'
data problems look a lot
like the data problems
that a lot of big
companies have.
And then there was an
awesome surprise at the end.
And you just have to watch
the video to find out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's a good teaser.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, teasers.
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm
good at teasers.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And a
lot of those showcases,
or some of the DevRellers
people that were up there,
are also the cool demos that
were over in the Dev Zone here
at the showcase floor.
So you could actually play
around with some of the stuff
that Felipe put
together with the BQML,
and of course, Emma's
Pi Day experiment.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, I forgot
that all that stuff's here.
And there was a recorded
tour of the showcase
that will hopefully
be up on YouTube
at some point in the next
couple of weeks, too,
so people can see.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: Did they
capture the pizza authenticator
that they had over there
in the showcase area?
AJA HAMMERLY: They did.
MARK MANDEL: In
fact, I think you can
go to it online from memory.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah,
all of the experiments
that came out of the
new online experiments
team, including
pizza authenticator,
are available online.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, if you
need to know specifically
what area of the world
your pizza comes from,
you can do that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There were
a lot of harsh discussions.
It started a lot
of animosity there.
It was surprising.
AJA HAMMERLY: People have
feelings about pizza.
LAUREN BUCHMAN: Yeah, Chicago
deep dish versus New York style
is like the tabs and
spaces of the food world.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right, Felipe?
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, thank you to both of
you for coming and hanging out
with us here in the booth.
I know it was a late
night last night.
So I appreciate you
putting in the effort.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thank you for
talking to us, Mark and Mark.
LAUREN BUCHMAN:
Yeah, thanks, guys.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks, all.
Hey, everyone.
So we're really excited to
have Yuri and Anthony here,
actually.
Anthony from Google and
Yuri from Scotiabank.
And of course--
MARK MANDEL: I'm here, too.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm here.
MARK MANDEL: Both Marks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Both
the Marks are here.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, both Marks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So first
of all, Yuri, who are you,
and what do you do?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Hey, so guys, thanks
for having me on the podcast.
And my name is Yuri Litvinovich.
And I'm a senior cloud engineer
working for Scotiabank.
And right now, I'm building
the cloud platform based
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
And Google is our big partner
in our digital transformation
journey that bank is
undergoing these days
for a number of years now.
And we're just starting.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
How are you enjoying
Google Kubernetes Engine?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
I really like it.
I really love it, I would say.
And this is something
that we've found
as a great technology
for a particular use
case of running applications
and running containers
in the cloud.
And we love the power of GKE as
a managed Kubernetes solution.
And--
MARK MANDEL: It's good.
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Yeah, it's really good.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I like
that tagline, right?
Google Kubernetes
Engine-- it's good.
MARK MANDEL: It's good!
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And so
what was kind of the summary
of the announcement that
y'all had with Google Cloud?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Oh, it was
another great Google Cloud
conference this year.
I really like the
advancement that Google Cloud
does in its technologies.
And in particular, I
really like Anthos--
how Cloud Services Platform got
its new name and all the powers
that came with it.
And this is something that
Scotiabank is interested in.
And our platform
that we're building
is called Cloud
Application Platform.
As I said, it's based on GKE.
We're going to utilize the power
of Anthos for that platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And you've been
working with Anthony on
the Google Cloud team
as well to kind of help your
team train up on Kubernetes.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Yeah, exactly.
Anthony did great Kubernetes
training for us some time ago.
And it got the team up to
speed to a higher level.
And yeah.
ANTHONY: I think the
coolest part is just
seeing kind of the excitement
across all the different teams
that kind of attended
this training here.
And I think that
it shows just kind
of how broad this space
for Kubernetes is, right?
There's certain features
that the security
team was interested in talking
about, so we dove into that.
There's a lot of networking
specific questions.
So it's just interesting
to see how kind
of Google Kubernetes Engine--
it's good.
That's the tagline.
MARK MANDEL: It's good.
It's good.
Marketing not equipped.
ANTHONY: Has really
brought a lot of features
across these different
spaces, right?
So if you look at security,
we have binary authorization.
If you look at some of
the container native load
balancing-- for folks
in these different kind
of specializations,
there's something for them
in Google Kubernetes Engine.
So it was exciting
to talk about--
with the team at
Scotiabank on that.
MARK MANDEL: It almost
sounds like we should
do a full episode on this.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, strange, hm.
YURI LITVINOVICH: I would be
happy to elaborate and tell you
guys more about the
exciting stuff we're
doing at Scotiabank.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
maybe perhaps possibly
stay tuned for what will
definitely be a full episode.
YURI LITVINOVICH:
And I would highly
recommend to watch
the presentation
by Justin Arbuckle, our
senior vice president.
ANTHONY: That's right.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
YURI LITVINOVICH: He
did a great keynote talk
on the latest state of things of
Scotiabank going to the cloud.
So definitely stay
tuned, and check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Have
you had a chance
to get to any presentations
or sessions here at Next?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Yeah, a bunch of them,
and I like talk about the
GKE secrets management
presentation.
That was a very good
deep dive on how
you integrate GKE clusters with
both third party key management
solutions, but also Google KMS
and definitely lots of things
to think about and also good
connections to work with.
ANTHONY: And that was
given by Seth Vargo, right?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Yeah, it
was given by Seth Vargo.
And also, Alexander--
MARK MANDEL: It's OK.
We'll have links
in the show notes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Don't worry.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Sounds good.
Sounds good.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I mean, I
think there's a
lot of cool talks
over the past couple
of days and today,
covering the entire ecosystem.
I'd be interested in hearing--
since you're doing such a
deep dive on Kubernetes,
what would you say the
top of your wish list is?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Oh,
that's a very good question.
And I can give you
a really big wish
list of things we would like
to have and in its full power.
But we're working on that.
And the partnership with Google
is very satisfying to us.
So I believe everything we
need, we'll get it done.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I like that.
All right, well, I think
we're just about out of time.
So anything else you
want to call out?
Where are you going to be?
Any other cool events coming
up that you want to talk about?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Oh, I'm very
happy with what we have here.
And I'm sure there are more
events coming like Google Cloud
Next next year, but
also the summit that's
happening in Toronto this fall.
I'm excited to-- I'm looking
forward to visiting that.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Yuri, thank you so much
for joining us on the podcast
and doing this
episode with us today.
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Thank you very much--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks, Yuri.
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Marks and Anthony.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Both
YURI LITVINOVICH: Both
Marks and Anthony.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks to
you, Andrew Davidson
from MongoDB for joining
us for our daily episode
here on the show floor.
Andrew, how are you doing?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Doing
great, thank you,
having a great time at Next.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
Very quickly, I want to
hear about your experience
here at Next.
But why don't you give us
a quick, like, MongoDB--
what is it?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Sure.
MongoDB is the most popular
modern general purpose
database.
And we're really excited to have
MongoDB Atlas close partnership
announced this week
with Google Cloud.
MongoDB Atlas is our global
database as a service.
Everyone should go out
and try it-- free forever,
free tier for everyone
to get started
and experience what
modern application
development with a database
that doesn't get in the way
could be like.
JON FOUST: You got Jon here,
and I got a couple of questions
about Next.
What is your favorite thing that
you've seen on the Next floor?
ANDREW DAVIDSON:
I've got to say,
on a big picture level,
I just love seeing
the level of excitement--
all of the companies
that are here,
everyone who's coming here to
really learn about Google Cloud
Platform to see how much
Google's really put into this,
that this is very much a big
part of the future of Google.
I feel that energy,
so it's real.
Talking to all of the
community members like MongoDB,
but all the others who you're
so open to working with,
I love seeing that.
It's really fostering
a great community.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
What's been some of your
favorite announcements
here so far?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: So I'm
pretty biased on that one.
I really love the
announcement of Google--
MARK MANDEL: That
seems reasonable.
ANDREW DAVIDSON:
Google announcing
MongoDB Atlas is an increasingly
deep partnership with Google,
including MongoDB Atlas as a
native part of the Google Cloud
console coming up
later this year.
Just in general, working
very closely together-- great
support from the Google team.
MARK MANDEL: So a short
teaser for our listeners--
I know we're going to have a
full episode with you coming
up later after Next,
but do you want
to tell them a little bit about
what we're going to talk about?
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Sure.
I mean, we're going
to talk a little bit
about the evolution
of databases over time
and why folks have shifted to
this new model of JSON document
style databases in
MongoDB and why getting it
as a service in the cloud
on GCP is just the easiest
way to modernize one's
application stack.
JON FOUST: And we're also going
to talk about Davidson's law.
MARK MANDEL: Apparently, Andrew
has his own laws of technology
now.
ANDREW DAVIDSON:
These guys named it.
No.
MARK MANDEL: Well, fantastic.
Well, Andrew, thank you so much
for coming to join us today.
Thank you so much for
being part of Google Cloud.
We look forward to hearing more
from you in a later episode.
ANDREW DAVIDSON: Thanks
so much for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so much for
everyone here at Next joining
us and everyone who
came past the booth.
It was great to see you all.
It was great to get interviews.
It was great to
get all the content
that we've got that we'll be
releasing in coming weeks.
So, see you all next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]